let's jump on to the next very big story
we have this from timcast.com Twitter
rebrands as X there it is ladies and
gentlemen Elon Musk is not sure what
subtle Clues gave it away but I like the
letter X and that's the new logo I
really like how he tweeted hey we're
gonna you know choose a logo if someone
tweets it or something but then just put
up the logo he already had planned
anyway love it he uh and his newly if
you get paid for engagement now so he
needs to keep that coming again this is
his plan to make money he's like I'm
gonna get myself bit he says and soon we
shall bid a dude to the Twitter brand
and gradually all the birds like this
but X so uh here we go this is always
been the plan he's been tweeting about
this for a long time it's official I
like that we've already got uh gang sign
is throwing up yeah Twitter Rex then it
might actually be a gang sign so you
should be careful because you know it's
true yeah no this one is this is blood
but you don't really see him anymore
because the cartels took over LA but
what do we call tweeting now and he said
it was called an X the more you know
I think I think it's is it exiting
exceeding I mean I like love big ziti
I think this is like a Gretchen Weiner's
moment we have to be like stop trying to
make acting happen it's not gonna happen
Elon Musk it's maybe not the only social
media site where there's actually a verb
for the word when you send a message I
just say like I'm sending a mess I post
it on mines I posted on YouTube my post
went live on Facebook but on Twitter it
was I my tweet went live so maybe it's
just going to be called posts you're
just posting on next yeah but that makes
it less unique like I don't understand
why you get rid of that brown that
branding uh my favorite truth no I don't
like that one it's hard that's why I was
sad when they didn't go with trumpet or
Trump trumpet and you'd be like
trumpeting something I thought that was
pretty cool but uh Chris degaldo radio
host tweeted out this picture of I don't
know what it's from but like some guy on
a crane in a basket like taking down the
to the bird logo off the side of a
building being like by birds that's why
he's making fun of it like with titter
to the WF because he doesn't care about
the brand he's but uh I wanna say this I
fear Elon musk's everything app I fear
xai his AI program Linda yaccarino says
the everything app will be powered by Ai
and I feel that this may actually be
somewhat apocalyptic yes and so I was
mentioning earlier that I was in Tijuana
went to the border and it's his big
fence there's Mexican National Guard on
one side and then there's US Border
Patrol on the other side and there's
just this huge hole that
the average person can easily just walk
right through and the only reason you
don't is because there's guards on the
other side
but I talked with some guy you know he
told me this crazy story our Uber driver
he was like I tried to climb the fence
to break into America and I fell 40 feet
because the car the human traffickers
took the ladder away from me and I'm
just like but I was talking about this
conversation before you go under it was
really crazy I was actually leaving but
um I Heard a story from some guy who
said back in the day a long time ago
yeah there's no border it was like if
you were a Mexican citizen you just
crossed and you'd work and then
Americans would cross and they'd work
and you'd walk back and forth yeah it
was no there was nothing there and now
there's this heavy border that's heavily
guarded and I think the issue is with
all of this and and this does relate to
the Twitter rebranding as X the uh
cultural collapse in its entirety
globally
everywhere in the world because of the
internet Community is ceasing to exist
we were talking at dinner about how
there's no Home Eck anymore right it's
at schools they used to teach women and
you know to some degrees I guess men
learn the stuff but mostly women would
learn how to cook dinner and prepare the
home and and iron clothes and help that
was extremely important in my opinion
yeah you had to take it once at least at
our school yeah same we talked about
last week with Libby Evans too on
Tuesday Yeah Tuesday Tuesday it was such
a staple that this was true at tons of
colleges they had schools of home
economics they would teach things like
budgeting they would teach things like
how to cost compare it was so big that
we had a federal department of home
economics that supported women during
war times and seeing how they could
support basically women helping to
sustain the nuclear family and we don't
have that anymore we have a thousand
things for diversity Equity inclusion
but we don't have things that are
specifically targeted to help people
help themselves in the context of
staying at home so to wrap it all
together yeah back to the Border
the reason I'm freaked out by this is
I'm like we needed this fence because no
one cares about their Community anymore
because now it used to be that someone
would say like hey you're not part of
our community we're we're concerned
about what you're doing here and they
would not get access to public goods
also there was no income tax so people
didn't really care all that much it just
meant you weren't going to fight for us
you weren't gonna be protected by us
Community starts breaking apart so we
have to build walls we have to create
laws why do we need a law that says you
you can't do a certain thing you know
example abortion Ron Paul says it
shouldn't be illegal it should be
Unthinkable how did it become thinkable
to the point where we need decree by
leadership and tell people what they can
or can't do instead of our people of the
United States just agreeing like hey we
shouldn't be doing this thing it's
simple culture is fragmenting and
breaking down which brings it all back
to Twitter
it used to be that uh you live next to
your neighbors you went to church you
talked to your neighbors you all agreed
on things you learned from each other
and you shared particular views based on
where you live then the internet came
around big cities started fragmenting
and now there's a dude who lives in New
York on top of another dude and they've
never even met even though they live
next literally next to each other for 10
years people don't talk to their
neighbors at all anymore exactly I
actually talked to mine and it's nice
but there's some on my blog I haven't
talked to because they're just
completely anti-social but it's because
of the internet of course it is so I
knew everybody on my blog before the
internet everybody nothing about this
AOC is not representative of the average
Democrat or average American she is
fringe leftist she's becoming more chill
establishment she gets elected because
she goes online and typically if you
were like a fringe leftist weirdo you'd
go outside and wave your weird leftist
flag and everyone would be like Sean
shun and you'd be like okay this is not
working now those people go online and
every person in every different part of
the country forms a community of ten
thousand and they share resources and
they organize and they they gain power
in this way I mean same can be said for
even this show we gain power from
everyone from all different all over the
world all over the country coming
together and watching and supporting us
this allows Fringe ideas to become
prominent now think about what it's
going to be like with AI controlling
what you see and hear it's already in
that we're already there
but now it's going to be no matter what
your crackpot insane view is the AI will
Pander to you and affirm your your your
Fringe belief system it's also like the
inner beyond the internet because that's
a really good point the internet is the
beginning of the fracturing of the local
community it's the cell phone you've
brought this up a few times it really
clicked with me a couple weeks ago this
thing it used to be that you'd be on the
internet when you sat down at your
computer you were there for an hour or
whatever then you got up and walked away
and you were not online ever for the
rest of the day everybody around you is
who you are with now these stupid things
when some you're trying to talk to
someone and they're on their
phone uh it's it's the most like
disheartening experience if you have a
friend and like they're just not
available because I call it dinner with
my family
yeah it's
so that's crazy well it is I mean have
you ever looked at your phone sometimes
and you re you've had a busy day doing
stuff that you've had to do and you look
and you go nine hours
and you just realize that's what you've
been doing for more than a work day is
staring at a screen so what's gonna
happen is horrific you're talking about
how it could even the AI is going to
start moving people like if you have a
brain implant or or a phone or like some
sort of sensor in your augment augmented
glasses and someone tells you something
and the machine's like they're lying
they're lying they're lying you're gonna
that's the AI making you think something
about that person like they're gonna
have behavioral monitoring devices and
stuff that people can tap into just is
this person a psychopathic behavioral
experimentation right we see this with a
Twitter algorithm or not just Twitter
but any of the social media algorithms
you know you'll get people who say oh
yeah we changed one small thing and we
saw this reaction so then we change this
way like they are already collecting all
data I can only imagine what AI is going
to decide it wants to do I don't trust
AI I don't like it at all I recognize
that there are some reasons why we're
curious about it but I think ultimately
just like Tim like the the idea that
we'd have this super app like where's
name one other place that has that China
I mean that's the idea right is China
has the one app that controls everything
that's what everybody sees all day is
the only one thing that monitors
everyone I mean that's the idea is the
government watches everybody on one
specific app is that what this is
how could it not be the fact that it
collects all that data like even though
we're not giving it to the government
necessarily the fact that everything
you're doing of course we've known this
since Snowden and we all yeah people
hated them even even it's like all he
did was tell us like what we needed to
know and it's like even even if Elon
disagrees with it even if Elon shuts
down these backdoors it doesn't mean
they're not going to look at it they
still can buy because they control the
grid I don't get it because Elon I think
of as like a brilliant genius like one
of the most genius strategists on Earth
right now why he would centralize data
it doesn't make any sense like you could
decentralize the system work on a mesh
Network maybe that's your goal overall
but why do you got to centralize
everything first it's such a
vulnerability point I'll tell you what I
think
I don't know this is absolute or true
but it's what's happening you think
about I think we talked about this in
one of the cultural episodes you think
about single-celled organisms what do
they do what are they doing Milling
about eating particles or whatever and
molecules and making more of themselves
I haven't the foggiest I haven't the
foggiest it seems irrelevant to us but
eventually a bunch of these little dudes
got together and created this massive
network of complicated specialized cells
to make us right
in our bodies when a group of cells goes
Rogue what do we call it
cancer yes and we destroy it yes because
it's deviating from what we want these
free radicals I love how they're called
free radicals that can like result in
cancer because I'm like that sounds like
the free radicals we have in society
that are running around doing crazy a
lot of fun young radicals are banned
yeah well it's either so here's what I
think is happening not a good band why
would Elon want this
so everybody you will live in you'll owe
nothing you will live in your pod you
will eat the bugs and you'll be happy
you this is the the Communist
techno-communist future
the next stage in the evolution of life
is multicellular organisms all becoming
hyper-specialized never deviating in any
way you are born to do a job you are
engineered to do a job probably
genetically the AI controls what you
think so you never deviate you never
want to deviate you're scared to
deviating if you do then you get removed
yeah and then what happens is the AI
will effectively be the brain telling
all of the individual multicellular
humans what the massive multicellular
multi-organism is supposed to be doing
the AI will effectively be the conscious
entity of all humanity and will be
nothing but a skin cell to be flicked
off and destroyed
I believe I shaved my dick for this
um with this though like if you look at
it I see what you're saying but okay
let's hear Elon Musk right you have
electric cars AI all these different
things that he's that he's doing which
one of the these things going towards
this does he not benefit from so even
though you look at him like a good guy a
genius these things that he that he does
don't you think that there could be a
chance that this maybe isn't the
greatest guy in the world and it could
be benefiting him completely yeah the
road to hell is paved with good
intentions that's what I mean he
couldn't he's always worried me in that
sense like I hate electric cars I'll
just say it but that's just because
maybe being from Detroit I just like the
feel of an actual car and that's just a
preference of mine but I don't get in a
Tesla and be like this is cool I just
it's something I don't enjoy personally
I like it but understand whether it's
Tesla or any other electric car oh I'm
not saying it's just his brand it's just
how I feel about it whatever car it is
there will come a day very soon yeah
where I'm not allowed to drive get in
the car and the doors will lock right it
says a warrant has been issued for Mr
Landau right driving to the police
station you know that sounds like your
fingerprints on the steering wheel or
something no the camera right there look
at your face face recognition says hello
Dave a warrant has been issued by
Precinct 99 and you'll be like okay I'm
like delivering you to jail that's why I
want like a older gas guzzler that has
none of those features I never love
those cars there are very few of them at
this point yeah they're trying to get
them away and but I think a lot of
people feel that way because lots are
filled with electric cars right now
people aren't buying them and I think
that's out of that fear I think descent
is part of the United States ethos like
if there's corrupt government you
descent create a better government by
the people like the people govern
themselves but the rest of the world's
not really built like that they they're
much about fall in line a lot of them
are like oh I think you're right about
that for sure and it's bleeding into our
culture I can feel it with this whole
like everyone organized on the centered
system it's better like the world
economic Forum they want everything like
monitored and now think about this
here's the real danger in my mind of
this hyper centralized AI dictating
everything yeah using the human body as
as the metaphor the next stage All
Humans specialized being controlled no
free radicals to be eliminated Etc the
ai's in control there are people whose
conscious minds are in control of their
bodies gorging themselves to death and
doing drugs and destroying their bodies
yeah and still when they get cancer we
destroy it
so that what freaks me out in that idea
is not not that's one for one but let's
say we do move in this direction where
AI controls everything we don't even
realize it the AI could be gorging
itself on drugs and sugars and we would
just be Milling about being like
everything so perfect until in the
entirety of humanity collapses we cannot
trust a centralized AI to make sure to
or or to follow or any of this and it's
where everything's been going in the
past couple of decades well and really
even in the past couple I don't know I
shouldn't even say months but really
it's already had so many problems with
AI that it's really like upsetting
people to the point that you have ice
cube you have other people speaking out
about the fears of it oh sorry am I not
lower it you're good sorry
um but you have you have people speaking
out against it you already have so many
problems with it just in I guess it's
not in its infancy but I think compared
to the you know technology it really is
there's already been so many issues with
this don't you think that there's other
places to go they're going to be far
more dangerous than just the tiny stuff
that we've seen yeah I I as you were
talking about how it's we're having
problems with AI I got this article from
fortune.com chat GPT went from correctly
answering a simple math problem 98 of
the time to just two percent of the time
so the way an AI can flip and be have
everything looks good and then one
little piece of data can switch in the
entire system can start outputting
something that's just slightly wrong but
that's just wrong enough to destroy the
entire thing it takes so much effort to
make it right and it's so easy to fail
have you guys seen where video games are
already at with this stuff dude it's
crazy it used to be
Super Mario Brothers Mario goes in the
castle and text appears thank you for
saving me but the prince is in another
castle that was the extent of NPC
communication with you it Advanced two
games now where you can choose to say
something and then a voice actor's
scripted line will speak that's a great
idea let's get the mission underway and
you're like cool now with text to voice
and predictive language models video
games have already started you're
wearing a headset you walk up to the NPC
and you say something like hey idiot
ugly I want to buy some soda and the a
the NPC goes who are you calling an
idiot if you want to buy something be
polite a generated predictive response
we are we are years away from people
saying I no longer want to live in
reality I'm going to go into this
universe where I can tune out and you're
going to be sitting in your living room
talking to fake people and we're we're
already there with the robot girlfriends
man y'all's getting crazy out there well
and how many people want to live in the
current reality
is it intense I mean it's not really
that great right now I mean the last
couple years everything has fallen
completely and I'm sure a lot of people
would prefer to live in the south I mean
I'm just saying it's in the headlines
that go behind that right like you're a
millennial they're saying it's gonna be
possible by a house it's gonna be
possible for a family like there's all
of these negative things at some point
it would be easy to be like I'm just
giving up like this place that gives me
Comfort and gives me the life I want is
easier right I can understand the
attraction of that I just think
ultimately that's really devoid of
actual emotional connection and support
I think part of the issue is that we
train people to uh seek out momentary
pleasure and comfort rather than work
through issues that they're having uh
well yeah it's easier to give up yeah
the idea of community and you take out
the idea of a lot of things like that
when you do want that instant
gratification which we've completely
taught our society to have as endless
dopamine hits and instant likes and no
attention span but then you add like the
other day I saw a video is for basically
gen Z's and Millennials where it's just
if you want to buy a 500 thousand dollar
house all you need is a twenty five
thousand dollar down payment and then
you need three thousand dollars a month
at a six point five percent interest
rate I'm like wow that sounds like hell
like pure hell to try to pitch that to
somebody it doesn't look good I mean
you're basically telling people that a
reality of the old of a way that life
once worked is no longer available but
it's a complete turn off I don't know
I'm just saying that's not like a
realistic it's not a realistic interest
rate it's not a realistic down pay it's
none of that it's all pretend I don't
just in that I don't agree that's bad uh
the the amount so the issue is
relativity and the issue with VR is that
will always offer you the greener grass
no matter what it is yeah you're not
going to go back 200 years and say that
we have it worse you know actually
there's there's no lights anywhere it's
dark out you could just die you stubbed
your toe you get infection you're dead
horrible things are going on and even as
bad as it is now relative to how things
may have been in economic booms or
whatever sure it's still pretty great of
course but there will always be struggle
there will always be problems and people
will always choose a free dopamine hit
over the harsh reality they live in yes
so when the VR starts coming out and
it's already here with predictive
language NPCs within a year or two the
language will be perfectly fluid right
now it's it's rather hey why are you
calling me ugly that was mean
it give it a year or two it's going to
be perfect I mean we went in in one year
with AI images I tweet out this horrible
image of Pelosi one year later you have
photorealistic images being made in my
mid-journey and getting better every day
dude I would picture like you play the
video game with the guy Elder Scrolls 7
or whatever and he's talking to you and
you're like then you're dreaming and
you're thinking about that one NPC like
that guy's really cool man and then
there's an app where you can actually
call that NPC on the phone when you're
not playing the game and bond with them
and talk to them and the next time
you're in the game they could make it so
the generative conversation was involved
or not involved oh dude no I don't like
that at all the only social skills you
have now though is that and and imagine
the people who are going to retreat to
significant others there's going to be
we're a year out from this at at most
people sitting in their living room
wearing a headset playing a video game
and talking to a computer programming
saying I love you so much and the
computer program just goes I love you
too I really wish I could be there with
you then how long until we download
those AIS into machines and it's here's
here's the thing so how long is it until
it's just porn and nobody leaves their
house ever that's exactly but but more
than for real like not even kidding but
emotional and physical porn at the same
day that's what I mean the hero yeah you
get to have sex with the woman it's
gonna be crazy yeah realistic I mean and
then it goes farther than that because
obviously we've taken something that and
I guess too what I mean by Nostalgia
isn't even 200 years if you looked When
We Were Young and the amount of the
amount of nostalgia that just we have in
our Generations is insane because of how
fast technology moved thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8 pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time